and I see Oh Ellie yeah oh my god thank
God
Excel my name is Rachel hey I'm Danny
hey I'm Annette and welcome to our cafe
today we're going to be competing in the
toughest challenge yet we're gonna spell
our customers names
what see I don't want to brag but I'm
pretty good at spelling people's names I
didn't know how to my name's a great big
wide range of initial talent but skill
is practice and all about texture but I
might surprise you may the best barista
win hi there how you doing Danny here hi
when I was in high school I actually
named my cowlick Merle the curl get out
no way it's my restaurant I'm gonna stay
in here we all know it it's gonna be an
F damn right M e and r are al no way off
okay we have an Al and then you know
what what we have another e at the end
of this name
I love it
me too I'm actually so happy everybody
always spells my name incorrectly so you
just made my whole baby M e are tricky
one
hi my name is Jana Jana oh my god the
hard one okay
Jana yes all right say slowly
Jana I think that there's a jack
J there's probably a night hey I'm gonna
go ahead and say an Jan Jan Dan hey
we're gonna go ahead and give you
another end because I feel like it
my name has two ends and finally we're
gonna end on an A but do we end on an A
Jana or do we have another silent letter
up in there keep it simple I'm gonna say
Jana you got it right so close I have
another N in my name I wasn't done just
kidding
J a and na thank you so much wrote it
correctly yeah
some people will put one end some people
put G or an H can I get out of here yeah
nah you forget out of here
[Music]
hello hello my name is Rachel Sarah oh
my gosh hello nice to meet you miss
Danny hi there welcome back how are you
hi I'm Rachel and I'm a former barista
for seven years
hi my name is MIA net now I guess and
I'm a barista for one and a half years
oh my god we just didn't mean I know
what Nicole Nicole Nicole hi Rachel my
name is Rachel hi Rachel Nicole I hope
it's like uh did you so I'm gonna say
that your name is RA chen2 Cole and I
see Oh Ellie yes oh my god thank God
except my name is Rachel oh not the best
beer in here named Nicole this okay
Rachel Oh
ACH e CH a yo
Yeah right
oh my gosh yeah but you got my name
right now it's actually our ACH al I
just wanted to throw you off because I
was butthurt okay hello hello what's
your name destiny destiny yes like the
child like the child
destiny my destiny is different this
right we got a deep we got it
see okay we got an e we got it I'm gonna
go ahead and say s that's right
s followed by a TT we're going with a I
NY and an E and then wait for it another
eat
[Music]
is the house above your name that is
wrong I thought so hey first of all I've
never seen it both like that so that's
uh Denis that's really creative so like
shadow to the death sticks with an egg
that's cool d es TI just to let you know
I do know how to spell that I want to
give you a big heart
[Laughter]
[Music]
doing well how are you doing what's your
name my name is destiny really yeah oh
you're gonna be a difficult choice you I
feel somehow like I'm getting a second
chance here it starts big ding GE e s
we're gonna go ahead and put an s in
there too if you feel confident about it
I do but now I done CT a she said she's
never met a destiny with an A we're
gonna go with the eye and why we're
gonna come ahead and give an in there
we're gonna put an e looks wrong to me
[Music]
I'll be even close you are close and
whatnot right there is another e well
mine is de STI and E hmm two E's no I
have a wonderful thank you they got me
so I feel like you got my name so my
friend actually is going to grab a
coffee okay
their name is me right me right mm-hmm
mm-hmm
so like you said who are you talking to
he said it's me right em i ry a n how
about you did it with such comfortable I
said I'm confident I'm not gonna scuff
it I'm gonna do an ir AE me ray Meyer on
me why wrong you know it's a really good
effort I mean you are beyond wrong like
I don't know if you could have gotten
more wrong but this is pretty good the
actual spelling oh yeah ll e we're
totally closed
told you to close good apologize to Mary
for me I'm gonna beat ya
I got tripped up a little bit but I
think I put in a valiant effort and also
there was definitely foul play involved
I'm almost positive I think I did
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
but hey you've got one who is Nicole
[Music]
okay I have no context for this joke but
I'm here for it
[Music]
you